[Musique]
alors après l'arrêt de double jeu j'ai
fait plein d'émissions c'est à dire
qu'entre le mois de janvier et le mois
de juin
j'ai fait trois émissions j'ai fait
autant en emporte le temps où
j'interviewais des gens du présent bien
sûr mais aussi du passé du futur
j'étais un truc une usine à gaz qui n'a
pas très bien marché faut dire la vérité
ensuite j'ai fait long courrier où je
partais dans une ville on l'a fait
relayer au par exemple soit disant
j'arrivais au coucher du soleil
et je re décoller au lever du soleil
c'était un peu comme un vampire quoi
sauf qu'on en a fait une
il fallait quinze jours pour la faire et
une émission hebdomadaire qui nécessite
15 jours pour être tourné ça marchait
pas et puis j'ai eu l'idée d'art d'imad
hardy matt c'est quoi je suis soit
disant en direct j'étais trop mauvais
pour être en direct malheureusement et
je cherche à faire le maximum d'audience
je suis prêt à tout pour faire de
l'audience un petit peu comme
aujourd'hui un jour je suis invitée dans
l'émission de cyril hanouna et pendant
la pub et regarder l'audience sur les
box et en fonction de l'audience sur les
box pendant la pub il fait pas
obligatoirement ce qu'il avait prévu de
faire après la pub
moi personnellement ça je l'avais fait
pour rigoler mais là lui le fait
vraiment donc voilà il y avait le
professeur rollin qui déjà géré tout qui
me critiquaient qui étaient là thierry
sous les verres l'audience offert 6 pour
faire ça voilà c'était c'était un
rapport à 2 si l'audience n'était pas au
rendez-vous j'avais prévenu les
téléspectateurs j'avais un chien sur le
bureau un petit caniche très mignon que
sap les apps et je disais ben voila si
vous ne regardez pas l'émission si je ne
fais pas assez d'audience je vais être
obligé de tuer ce chien
les gens y croyaient vraiment j'avais un
gros flingues the pointer sur le
chasselas ap ap ap gerland dans le tue
pas si je vais le tuer bon là et on
faisait plein de trucs
rageant pour diffuser du porno mais
comme on était sûr service public c'est
un peu difficile de diffuser du
parlement divisé du porno à l'envers
donc la sortie du magnéto tout le monde
était comme ça en train de regarder le
porno on a fait les comiquement ce
marché très bien les comics morts les
enfants comiquement les femmes de
comiquement à une mise en abîme de la
télé je me souviens que dans les comics
mort j'avais mis
guy bedos et à la sortie du magnéto le
professeur rollin me dit mais thierry
mais non mais guy bedos n'est pas morte
et régis mer et là-dessus guy bedos a
développé une semaine on se finit par se
réconcilier
il avait trouvé ça ils croient qu'ils
voulaient que tu es vraiment quoi alors
c'est un gag mais bon les humoristes
sont pas ceux qui ont le plus d'humour
souvent on faisait des castings de
potiche
alors on faisait défiler les filles qui
faisait tourner la détourner une roue et
puis un jour il ya corti carrés avec une
perruque blonde courtes pattes rome
patron du coup philippe pas vraiment là
dessus il voulait absolument rentrer
dans l'émission j ai assez ridicule un
jour il s'est déguisé en chien
il était ancien comme ça sur le bureau j
je vais tuer le chien
oh non pas 30 c'est moi c'est philippe
ne me tue pas mon accord donc voilà donc
c'était quand même assez bordélique
j'ai interviewé une dinde comme si elles
étaient sophie favier
j'ai interviewé un âne comme s'ils
étaient francis lalanne un cheval comme
s'il était fanny ardant et le jour j
interviens gloria lasso qui est une
chanteuse que plus personne ne connaît
j'ai interviewé un lasso et une boîte de
lait gloria quand c'était vraiment
surréaliste raconte sur la liste et un
jour soit 10 ans j'étais en retard et
j'ai commencé l'émission dans une cabine
téléphonique avant j'étais aux champs
elysées dans une cabine en verre 11 ans
chers amis bonjour bienvenue et tout et
pendant ce temps rollin faisait
patienter le public dans dans l'émission
sur le studio en leur chantant chanter
comme une souris risque quoi et moi je
faisais de la cabine téléphonique
un autre jour je sors du plateau pour
aller chercher francis huster à la
sortie de sa pièce de théâtre avec une
soupière
qu'est ce que tu fais je viens te servir
la soupe voilà quand j'allais peas et on
mettait le pont de la rivière kwaï et
les gens sifflent et le pont de la
rivière kwaï jal épicé au sous-sol du
studio la caméra me suivez je m'écoutais
la queue et je remontais continuer
l'émission ça vous le verrez plus jamais
à télé et quand l'audience bcge était
puni ma punition c'est un documentaire
ultra cyan sur venise l'audience marché
pâtit reeves est mauvais vous avez 30
secondes de venise bon la semaine
d'après roland 10 et tirent il ya eu une
erreur la semaine dernière
1 je vous ai donné trente secondes de
venise mais en fait c'était 32 secondes
donc on va regarder deux secondes de
légèreté c'était incroyable lorsque je
vous recommande dans cette émission
c'est d'abord de voir les 7 parce
qu'elle n'a que sept finalement ça s'est
très vite arrêté il ya pierre perret un
jour qui arrive à l'entrée qui dit non
on peut pas te laisser rentrer t'es pas
dans le genre de l'émission mais tu
viens pourquoi et là il fait sa promo à
l'entrée sur le trottoir divorce contre
uc le pauvre pierre perret voilà c'est
une émission incroyable
regardez les toutes les corrections de
ne rien rater de inhabituel abonnez vous
y mettez un pouce bleus